[Música]
seguro que muchos de vosotros os habéis
manchado los pies de alquitrán alguna
vez en la playa yo sí muchas sobre todo
de pequeño después de estar todo el día
jugando en la orilla llegaba el momento
de irse a casa y había que sacudirse los
pies para subirse al coche y nada para
ahí aparecía esa manchita negra en la
planta del pie la odiaba y no por la
mancha en sí que me daba igual sino por
la fase posterior de limpieza en la que
mi madre con un algodón citó manchado en
aceite de oliva se pasaba portando me la
planta del pie toda la tarde del domingo
para mí en aquel momento aquello formaba
parte de la playa como el agua como los
peces como la arena
mucho tiempo después en los días
posteriores al 13 de noviembre de 2002
se mostraban por televisión las
terribles consecuencias del hundimiento
del buque prestige que se fue a pique a
250 kilómetros de la costa gallega
teniendo la de negro con las 77 mil
toneladas de fue el pesado que llevaban
sus bodegas
esto
es una muestra de la carga que llevaba a
que el barco en sus bodegas
fijaos
los que estáis arriba no lo leyes pero
hacerme caso huele fatal
bueno pues fue observando esa marea
humana de héroes y heroínas que
voluntariamente se fueron a recoger el
chapapote con sus manos a la playa
cuando me di cuenta de que aquello que
les manchaba a ellos los trajes y esas
manos era exactamente igual que lo que
me manchaba a mí la planta de los pies
cuando era pequeño
y si no se le parecía mucho
nunca he sabido de ningún accidente en
frente de las costas de málaga allí
donde yo me bañaba de pequeño saber lo
que sí que durante mucho tiempo pues una
plataforma de descarga de productos
petrolíferos
bueno de las consecuencias de un vertido
en el mar no hay amplia documentación
por resumir malformaciones cambio de
comportamiento muerte en los peces y
cetáceos extinción de especies vegetales
y algas desaparición del plancton que es
la base de la cadena alimenticia marina
el petróleo al degradarse en el mar
desprende unas sustancias químicas
altamente cancerígenas pues eso sí entra
dentro de la cadena alimenticia primero
marina y después humana
los peces al volar y ver las manchas de
petróleo en el mar las confunde con
islotes entonces se acercan y quedan
impregnadas de la sustancia
perdiendo muchas veces su capacidad para
el vuelo y otras lo que pierden es la
impermeabilización de sus plumas
condenadas igualmente a morir de frío
la llegada de un vertido a costa supone
unas consecuencias altamente dramáticas
no hay manera humana de separar el
chapapote de la arena y si el petróleo
llega a las rocas bueno pues a ver quién
es el guapo que se va con una cartera
darle con agua caliente a presión a los
espigones y no lo digo en broma es que
no hay otra manera un vertido en costa
es la desaparición de playas entornos
naturales piscifactorías caladeros de
marisco en definitiva unas consecuencias
económicas y medioambientales
devastadoras
pero bueno que yo he venido a contaros
el rollo con visiones catastróficas yo
os he venido a contar como la tecnología
nos va a ayudar a cuidar de los océanos
tres mil millones de personas dependen
directamente de la biodiversidad marina
y nuestros océanos generan más oxígeno
que todos los bosques del planeta
bueno soltamos ahora seis años y nos
vamos a octubre de 2008
en ese momento empiezo a trabajar en un
laboratorio
de detección y análisis de contaminación
marina y lo que más me gusta de mi
trabajo es que está a bordo de un avión
del avión de salvamento marítimo si
llevo 10 años viendo manchas de petróleo
en el mar y no solo a través de la
ventana sino gracias a un montón de
sensores de teledetección que me
permiten ver desde allá arriba todos los
vertidos si podemos detectar los medir
los y analizarlos sin necesidad de tocar
el agua
en estos años he aprendido algo un par
de cosas muy interesantes la primera es
que existen los aviones en los que se
puede estirar las piernas cuando uno va
sentado
la segunda es que cada año terminan en
el mar desechos de productos
petrolíferos en una cantidad equivalente
a 20 veces la descarga del prestige y
eso porque no salen los medios
bueno pues porque sólo la décima parte
es consecuencia de accidentes como los
del prestige según un estudio de la
academia de ciencias de los estados
unidos- realizado en 2003 hasta un 40
por ciento proviene de descargas
operacionales en la extracción y el
transporte dicho de otra manera cada año
se vierten en el mar cientos de miles de
toneladas de desechos del petróleo
lanzados deliberadamente con la única
intención de ahorrarse el dinero que
cuesta reciclar los esto es básicamente
lo mismo que si a mí cuando me toca
cambiar el aceite al coche pues decido
hacerlo en la playa porque no quiero
pagar la ecotasa que me cobra el taller
bueno pues cientos de estas descargas
operacionales que es un bonito eufemismo
para no decir crimen medioambiental han
sido vistas desde nuestro avión durante
todos estos años la mayoría de veces las
detectamos de forma aislada pero algunas
aparecen conectadas a la estela en
navegación de un buque en esos casos se
inicia un proceso sancionador que suele
acarrear fuertes multas esto hará que la
próxima vez se lo piensen dos veces
antes de hacerlo
este sistema de monitorización con
aviones y sobre todo esas multas han
conseguido
un efecto disuasorio que nos ha
permitido reducir sensiblemente la
contaminación en el mar
desgraciadamente seguimos viendo todavía
muchas manchas
cuántas pues honestamente no tenemos ni
idea de la dimensión real del problema y
ya hemos visto que el problema es muy
serio
no podemos cuidar lo que no conocemos y
no conocemos lo que no podemos ver para
eso el mejor de los sensores de nuestro
avión puede ver 15 kilómetros a cada
lado del avión aquí vemos una imagen de
ese sensor con una bonita estela
contaminada
pues en un vuelo de los nuestros somos
capaces de ver unos 30 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de contaminación lo cual no
está nada mal es como 5 veces el área
total de la provincia de granada
desgraciadamente no podemos estar
volando todo el día y la mayoría de esos
barcos que deciden descargar
ilícitamente sus sentinas al mar pues lo
hacen sin ser vistos la vista de pájaro
está muy bien pero qué tal si subimos un
poquito más alto por ejemplo a 800 km a
bordo del satélite
esta es una imagen del satélite envisat
tomada de la catástrofe del prestige en
una imagen tomada en unos pocos segundos
tenemos el conocimiento de dónde está
toda la superficie contaminada pudiendo
actuar muy eficazmente contra contrarios
a la contra se vertido tardaríamos días
en tener toda esa información con
nuestros aviones os acordáis que la
catástrofe del prestige la presencia en
los medios de comunicación era total no
había telediario que no abriera sus
primeros minutos hablando del prestige y
del hundimiento y del chapapote en la
playa si algo bueno pudimos sacar de
aquello fue que se genera una conciencia
ambiental más o menos generalizada en
todo el mundo
a lo mejor no en todos
y más pocas millas al norte del prestige
de un par de barcos decidían descargar
sus sentinas también ilegalmente
aprovechando que el pisuerga pasa por
valladolid
bueno pues durante todos estos años
hemos tenido unas ayudas muy
interesantes la unión europea tiene
establecido un sistema de monitorización
satelital de la superficie de la
superficie marina
tiene ahora mismo unos tres o cuatro
satélites de tecnología a radar que nos
da una información de cada posición del
mar varias veces a la semana
esta es una imagen de uno de esos
satélites tiene un ancho de barrido de
250 kilómetros y también podemos ver
estelas contaminadas toda esta
información es enviada de forma
estrictamente confidencial a las
agencias de cada país encargadas de la
lucha contra la contaminación y ellos
pues ya decidirán si actúan en
consecuencia en función de su normativa
saltamos ahora un momento que va a
suponer un antes y un después para todos
los que nos dedicamos a observar el
planeta desde arriba
en febrero de 2017 hace dos años las
agencias espaciales norteamericanas y
europeas la nasa y la esa deciden
liberar todas las imágenes de todos sus
satélites
solo es necesario hacerse una cuenta en
sus páginas webs y te puedes descargar
cualquier imagen de los mejores sensores
que existen en la actualidad y si bueno
para facilitarla
el análisis pues se ha abierto una serie
de portales en internet con los cuales
puedes ver cualquier imagen de sus
sensores sin necesidad de descargarse un
poco como el google maps pero pero del
espacio bueno pues esto significa que
cualquier persona desde su casa con su
ordenador personal y una simple conexión
a internet puede observar todo el
planeta todos los días con los mejores
sensores del mundo
yo no sé a vosotros pero a mí esto me
vuela la cabeza
entonces como la cabra tira al monte me
puse a investigar un poquito con los
sensores estos que utiliza la unión
europea' y si efectivamente pude empezar
a ver las manchas que se hacían aquí en
españa pero también las del resto del
mediterráneo y el mar rojo y el mar
negro y el atlántico y el pacífico
no creéis podéis ni creer la cantidad de
contaminación que se puede observar con
un satélite de estos es un problema
global que requiere soluciones globales
bueno hasta ahora sólo se ha hablado de
tecnología radar que es que es cojonuda
porque puede ver el planeta de día y de
noche incluso a través de las nubes es
tan buena tan buena que toda la
comunidad científica siempre ha pensado
yo incluido que es la única tecnología
válida para observar los vertidos en el
mar
pero bueno como resulta que entre todos
estos satélites gratuitos que nos ha
puesto a nuestra disposición la esa y la
nasa pues hay un montón de satélites que
tienen otra tecnología que es óptico
básicamente como si fueran cámaras de
fotos con un súper zoom pero que además
ven otros colores que los ojos que los
humanos no vemos así sobre todo en el
espectro del infrarrojo esos satélites
están pensados sobre todo para estudiar
el clima y para observar la vegetación y
sobre todo para ver paisajes tan
alucinantes como como esté bueno pues
observando así haciendo un paseo entre
el desierto del gobi y el estrecho de
gibraltar por casualidad o por
serendipia pues me topé con algo a lo
que estoy muy acostumbrado a ver desde
la ventana de mi avión eso es un barco
descargando todos sus desechos en el mar
en el mediterráneo frente a las costas
de argelia
y estos sensores no están hechos para
ver el mar
menos mal porque en pocas semanas en
casa tengo analizados y categorizados
más de 300 vertidos solo en el
mediterráneo en 2018 y 30 buques in
fraganti
y si además os digo que existen 11
satélites gratuitos libres a todos
vosotros con capacidad de detectar un
vertido cualquiera de vosotros puede
poner observar cualquier tipo de crimen
medioambiental y ponerlo en conocimiento
de las agencias de todo el mundo pero es
que además existen muchísimos satélites
de las propias agencias espaciales de
los diferentes países con capacidad para
ver más vertidos eso no está libre para
todo el mundo pero también pueden
utilizarse pero es que resulta que a día
de hoy el espacio se está democratizando
existe la tecnología espacial ahora
mismo es exponencial y existen decenas
de constelaciones privadas que van a
poner en pocos años cientos de satélites
en órbita con capacidad para haber un
vertido de aquí a muy poco vamos a poder
tener por fin un conocimiento real y
global de la contaminación en el mar y
lo que es más importante podremos ver
siempre quién la está causando pudiendo
actuar en consecuencia
de aquí a poco podremos acabar
finalmente con todos esos prestige que
se unen silenciosamente en frente de
nuestras costas pudiendo cuidar nuestra
principal fuente de alimento y oxígeno y
lo que es más importante que ningún niño
vuelva a mancharse los pies de alquitrán
en la playa fastidiando sus tardes de
verano muchas gracias
[Aplausos]